Let's flip this around, keeping the light fixed and showing the effect on the
sphere. In fact, throughout this unit, let's assume each light is extremely far
away like the sun. So, we can just look at its direction instead of its
position. That way, we don't have to think about the light's direction changing
as the surface changes position. Here, the sphere's normal changes with respect
to the light. The light's effect is at a maximum at the top of the sphere, goes
to 0 at the equator, and stays that way since the bottom of the sphere faces
away from the light. This is what the diffused term looks like when the sphere
it is lit from above. This next point is a little subtle but I think it's worth
going through. A diffused material is defined as one that scatters light in all
directions above the plane according to this cosine law. So, this green shows
how the amount of light gathered actually drops off as the angle gets steeper.
That is, the amount of light from a single point on a surface drops off with the
cosine of the angle, the surface compared to the eye. So, you might think less
light would hit the eye when the surface is viewed from a shallow angle.
However, a balancing factor is that, as the angle of the surface to the viewer
increases, the area of the surface visible through the pixel proportionally
increases. That is, you see more of the surface even though less light per unit
area is reflected towards the eye. These offsetting effects give the net result
we want. The viewers location doesn't matter at all. As the shade of the surface
depends only on the angle to the light itself. Not needing the eye direction
makes the diffuse term faster to compute, which is always important at an
interactive rendering.